huyen de la violencia la crisis
económica agravada por la pandemia y los
estragos dejados por los huracanes eta
idiota
lo sacan
son miles los hondureños que hacen parte
de esta nueva caravana partieron de san
pedro sula e ingresaron a guatemala a
través de el florido un punto fronterizo
en el que según las autoridades
rompieron dos cordones de seguridad y
las exigencias sanitarias pues muchos no
cuentan con prueba negativa de ccoo y 19
su objetivo es llegar a eeuu donde
esperan ser acogidos por la
administración de joe biden que asume la
presidencia el 20 de enero si salimos
del país no arriesga más que cualquier
cortando pase pero si lo logramos
llegamos a eeuu nos dan asilo político
llevamos la meta de trabajar por familia
pero el camino se ve plagado de
obstáculos desde el viernes méxico
ordenó el despliegue de cientos de
agentes migratorios para enfrentar lo
que ha sido denominado un flujo
migratorio masivo en diciembre by then
conversó con el presidente andrés manuel
lópez obrador y ambos resaltaron la
necesidad de estudiar posibles
estrategias para enfrentar las
migraciones masivas
si estos caminantes son acogidos por la
nueva administración se podrían generar
nuevas caravanas de lo contrario otros
centroamericanos podrían desanimarse de
abandonar sus países